hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to the escapist we are
continuing with our devious plan to
escape from this horribly oppressing
prison in the prison guards who don't
know what Liberty means or blah blah
blah blah whatever so I need to go to
roll call bla bla bla
come on come on come on come on tell me
how good I am don't search my crap
because I got a little out of crap in
there and I want to be able to crap that
up in a good stuff count time the
following darlings have won a Cell
search not me no hey no not me not dummy
ya bunch of liars
you bunch of liars oh I'm taking the
battery the soap cookie bleach plastic
knife file uh no duh put them enough
buzz enough yes uh bleach I don't need
bleach oh you got a laundry room Oh
cookie
I gotta abandon the cookie for now ah
good enough I'm in Rome Gaul I'm here
I mean someone stole the wardens to pay
no warden may be visiting today
probably not we suspect an escapist
among us nollie boys will be Santa Paula
Terry definitely not me I'm not a
naughty boy
so when are you gonna search my cell be
first food food food yum yum yum in my
tum tum why are you beating up a
prisoner already nah I didn't why did he
get in front of me
my crap what a bunch of baloney that's a
bunch of baloney I wasn't even ago was I
in combat mode the whole time ah I look
so bad in front of the Internet I look
like such a maroon I looks like side
jadid Livi I can't even talk I'm such a
doof okay
ah I just got my food ah there's so much
funky free period I'm gonna escape this
sumbitch okay I had a file but
unfortunately I'm gonna have to loot
through my fellow prisoners stuffs again
let's see what ego bomb bomb has asked
for
bottle of medicine that'll probably give
me some price money miss give other
people of getting this you know what I
mean whatever okay toothbrush plastic
knife I feel like a plastic knife would
be able to do something I don't know how
often these guys get new stuff
now I've already looted these guys
mmm-hmm
how do I escape I have no idea how to
escape maybe if it's like it was in the
demo there's got to be a vent so where's
the vent system get down from there you
you can't you can't talk to me like that
you screw okay so I got to figure out
how to get the vent open which means I
need a screwdriver type device which
means that I neither need to get it from
someone or I need to work a job where I
can get it so what that means I don't
have any visitors okay
license okay cleaning supplies mail room
file maybe I can get it wow this is
fight going on here oh I'm just gonna
I'm gonna loot old cinammon he's got
cooked food on him that's good I guess
I'll just eat that up I guess well good
for me I stole food from an unconscious
man okay so if I could work in the as a
janitor ah I bet there this is probably
like I want to do that I want to do that
how do I do that
resign give him my god damn it Bob metal
shop that probably Jack with that
problem that priming that Jack has
something I'll stick with the laundry
for now
I'm gonna get you guys I get you guys
okay I don't know where Jax stuff is cuz
if Jax stuff is elsewhere I'm gonna go
get lunch I don't need to get lunch I'm
not hungry
I can go get lunch ah ha ha jab step to
dig yeah bet you got something for me
baby a cup you have a cup
screw you jab sup to dig come on good
god no one has anything good no one even
has a sock yarr mirrors match that
sounds good
postcard not good spatula totally
contraband the bottle notes in a way you
meet the bachelor I made an even trade
it's all fair look at Bob don't see me
you didn't see me I I'm not in the cell
what are you talking about I'm not doing
it I'm coming I'm coming
coming along don't be me up I'm don't
beat me up don't beat me up hello how
are you missing the god dammit I just
got my Wow
oh no no I'd wanted to steal okay all
right then
I guess I'll just go on my way and do my
laundry duties why do I need to do it
anyway god I don't want to do it I don't
wanna I don't wanna I don't think it was
anything in the there's nothing in here
that could have possibly helped me
anyway oh Jesus
I gotta [ __ ] I'm working it took my
spatula
he took my spatula all right I really
got to figure out how to get out of here
but I know that it probably has to do
with me stealing one of these outfits
and moving along because that's like the
only thing that I know right now but I
know there's got to be more
there's gotta be more to this I know I
I'm missing a lot of stuff and I know
that I'm not like being the most expert
at this game but bear with me it's gonna
oh boy it's gonna be good
I think I got like tossed up to the
upper there we go yeah I jumped up on ah
okay so there's a vent
up there I go up to there oh [ __ ] I
needed that put it on the ground put it
on the ground on the ground put on the
ground you dingus gonna drag it how do I
put on the ground before I put it on the
ground
hey take this I'm not a janitor huh oh
just put on the ground okay I gotta go
drop it up I don't know how it didn't
get to the point where I couldn't drop
it off whatever it happened before least
I saw my cookie earth Danny's cookie
yeah I'm getting back god damn all right
give me in here give me that
don't beat me up man
yeah I'm gonna take one of these guard
outfits I'm gonna take this particular
one I'll be on my way because you think
I should be working doesn't mean I
should be working taking away my job
that's okay I got plenty of job all
right
exercise period go exercise with the
bruise check out these quad oh I just I
was there I was there y'all some metal
shop yes yes yes wait 40 it Stephanie em
put em to em to collect but I'm totally
an intellectual what are you talking
about I'm so super smart I think I sit
with my step oh god I'm so dumb I'm very
very dumb all right so there's got to be
some way that I can got to be some way
that I can get some sort of tool to be
able to get out of here
fine fine hey he's out damnit Ikhwan no
no yeah room timber glass shank yes
please
why did you go have a
Hank I don't know but it's fine now I
got it just little old me
don't worry she my able to put that on
me right now cuz if I can knock out one
of these officers I should be able to
take either their outfit or a key that
they have and then I would be able to
there's a lot of funny jokes going on
here a lot a lot of funny jokes going on
I should be able to get what I need to
get out if that's the case but these
guys can whack me and it's like I'm out
period and back evening meal I'm all the
way yum yum yum yum yum gimme gimme
gimme food food food I'm so hungry I'm
so hungry I'm actually gonna eat today
Jake give me that you down nothing okay
no one wants to eat with me really no
let's eat with me
just cuz I'm screaming to myself as I'm
walking around announcing my plans to
the world and anyone that can listen to
me but let me they all have to shun me
sitting over here with wherever you tend
out about it down out of turn Danny
spilled all my dirty little secrets of
the warden to cut his sentence worth a
beating I'd say I would never beat
yarman army oh well mataman merriman de
mer why did he do that huh
these guys are a little overly emotional
it is dinner over yeah thank you
evening free time okay so what I'm gonna
do is I'm gonna equip the glass shank
which actually Oh Oh glass shard I can
make another comb blade I don't know how
he made a comb blade but I love it
okay so I'm gonna get one of these
officers unfortunately it seems like I
have to shank them hey phone maybe I
could get some tips and tricks wouldn't
be too bad guard towers limit your
actions outside during the day but at
night it's a different story
interesting
hmm hello officer Stewart
hello off the suit okay probably not the
best idea to do it in the middle of
broad daylight officer Stewart officers
to do what what the hell is this I
didn't even know this place existed I
didn't even know we were allowed to roam
this much I need to shankha officer god
that sounds bad but I gotta do it to
escape I think maybe uh huh this
somewhat like I have no idea what to do
but it's really really interesting to
try to figure it out
why not for you guys because you're like
are you gonna have to do the blah blah
and blah blah and I'm like oh I had no
idea
okay so there's gotta be something I can
do to sneak up on an elf sir out of view
of everyone else
oh one on ow that hurt a lot
oh that was not a good idea ow okay well
that was not a good idea
apparently oh oh no no I thought my
health was like really really low or
something and I thought I had a maximum
of 100 okay so I lost my shank and my
glass shard
so obviously shanking them is not the
right idea because I wouldn't able to
get them down No
no dammit I feel like I haven't done
anything
I really feel bad outer doors lock at
12:20 - what do you mean outer doors
lock floors a lock Oh out of doors to
the Courtyard okay so I have to figure
out some way some way let me listen to
your drivel again one more time as they
try apologize I'm really trying to Rack
my brain to figure this out fine body
and then what do you what are you trying
to say they're lovelies about to get
their cell searched our dude your gin
bourbon oh boy
why anyone would on escape this place
beyond me someone devoured all the cuz
that bastard I'd like to commend you all
for what your needs are our utmost
concern okay
someone devoured us that bastard some
interesting developments yes please give
let's give off the Apollo of course okay
lights out but this is this is totally
good
plotting time so
okay so the vent is anyway the vent is
over there but I don't have anything to
open the vent with unless I could try to
use like I don't know some glass shard
oh no I'm locked in my cell bollocks
damn it I thought oh I'm so bad at this
game I'm so bad
ah I won't if I want to at least get to
the point where I can escape before I
start doing this again like
unfortunately no no I'm not gonna leave
it at this I'm now I'm not gonna leave
I'm gonna I'm gonna that day never
happened you just saw failure this is a
new day this is a brand-new day this is
the day that I'm gonna escape this damn
place following our do to a Cell toss
ego bomb bomb and Young Buck I got
nothing
I got nothing apparently someone escaped
but soon returned some interesting
development God you see you dribbles so
annoying naughty boys will be sent to
solitary I need to have a good plan God
that was a terrible plan okay you know
what I'm gonna figure this I'm gonna
read walkthrough or something try to get
away so that I can get to the point
where I can actually escape I'm sorry
for these two episodes of failures but
that's what it is so live with it I'm so
sorry tell me I'm an idiot God to me Sam
an idiot either way thank you all so
much for watching check out the other
videos that I've done in the description
below and as always I will see you in
the next video bye bye
what are you doing that bus stopped at
me
stop it grille version of me stop
humping that bus